This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Every week we look at human behavior through the lens of social science research. Today we turn our attention to history and the untold stories that so often lie beneath it. When I see the statues and the memorials to simps, what I see is what's not shown. We'll also look at how, as William Faulkner might say, the past is never dead. It's not even past. Black kids with fractures go into an emergency room and do not get the same level of anesthesia as white kids. We'll also hear from poet Bettina Judd on who gets credit for medical advances,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。每周我们都通过社会科学研究的视角来审视人类行为。今天我们将关注历史以及常常隐藏其下的鲜为人知的故事。当我看到那些针对西姆斯（Sims）的雕像和纪念碑时，我看到的是那些未被展示的东西。我们还将探讨威廉·福克纳可能会说过的那句话：过去从未死去。它甚至没有过去。骨折的黑人儿童进入急诊室，得到的麻醉水平与白人儿童不同。我们还将聆听诗人贝蒂娜·贾德（Bettina Judd）关于谁该为医学进步获得赞誉的讲述，
and who doesn't. Sims invents the speckulum. I invent the wind sing. If you must of it, the looking away. There is a statue in South Carolina honoring a man who is known as the Father of Modern Gynecology. The inscription on the statue reads, the first surgeon of the ages in ministry to women, treating alike, impress, and slave.
以及谁没有获得。西姆斯发明了窥阴器。我发明了风歌。如果你必须这样做，那就是移开视线。南卡罗来纳州有一尊雕像，是为了纪念一位被称为“现代妇科之学之父”的人。雕像上的铭文写着：历代第一外科医生，致力于服务妇女，平等对待女皇与奴隶。
J. Marion Sims was a physician who was born in South Carolina in 1813. This is Vanessa Northington Gamble. She's a physician and medical historian at the George Washington University. We asked her to come in to tell us the story of Jay Marion Sims, who is memorialized in statues not only in South Carolina, but also in Montgomery, Alabama, and Central Park in New York City. He started a clinic in Montgomery, Alabama, and at the time, in order to survive financially, he also was a plantation
J·马里恩·西姆斯（J. Marion Sims）是一位医生，1813年出生于南卡罗来纳州。这位是瓦妮莎·诺灵顿·甘布尔（Vanessa Northington Gamble）。她是乔治华盛顿大学的医师和医学史学家。我们请她来给我们讲述J·马里恩·西姆斯的故事，不仅在南卡罗来纳州，而且在阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利市以及纽约市中央公园都有为他建立的纪念雕像。他在阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利开办了一家诊所，当时为了在财务上维持生存，他同时也是一个种植园
physician, where he took care of the enslaved one plantations. This is where the story of Sims becomes complicated. Because yes, the inscription on a statue in South Carolina is true. He did invent techniques that help women to this day. He treated slaves as well as high society. He once treated Empress Eugenie, the last Empress of France. But there is something not mentioned on the inscriptions on the statues. Starting in 1845, he started to conduct experiments on enslaved women. And why we talk about Sims today and why that statue was there is that he perfected a technique to repair a condition called vesico vaginal fist ja. And let
医生，照顾种植园里的奴隶。这就是西姆斯的故事变得复杂的地方。因为是的，南卡罗来纳州雕像上的铭文是真的。他确实发明了至今仍能帮助女性的技术。他既治疗奴隶，也治疗上流社会的人。他曾治疗过法国末代皇后欧仁妮皇后。但雕像上的铭文没有提及一些事情。从1845年开始，他开始对被奴役的女性进行实验。我们今天谈论西姆斯的原因以及这座雕像之所以存在，是因为他完善了一种修复被称为膀胱阴道瘘的病症的技术。让我
me tell you what that means. It basically means that there is an opening between the vagina and also the bladder or the vagina and the rectum, which usually comes after traumatic childbirth, and sims started in 1845, 1846, according to some sources, a series of experiments to repair these fistulas. This condition was highly stigmatized
告诉你这意味着什么。这基本上意味着阴道与膀胱之间，或者阴道与直肠之间出现了一个开口，通常发生在创伤性分娩之后，西姆斯在1845年、1846年（根据某些资料），开始了一系列修复这些瘘管的实验。这种疾病受到高度污名化，
and dangerous for these women. There was no treatment. So on the one hand, you could say Sims was doing what doctors are supposed to do by taking these women on his patients. But there's another site to what Sims did. He wanted to be a trailblazing researcher, and these women, their bodies, became props in his journey of scientific discovery. These women were property.
对这些女性来说也很危险。当时没有治疗方法。所以一方面，你可以说西姆斯把这些女性当作病人来治疗，是在做医生应该做的事。但西姆斯的所作所为还有另一面。他想成为一名开创性的研究人员，而这些女性以及她们的身体，成了他科学探索之旅中的道具。这些女性是财产。
These women could not consent. These women also had value to the slave holders for production and reproduction. How much work they could do in the fields. How many enslaved children they could produce, and by having these fistulas, they could not continue with childbirth, and also have difficulty working. There are ten slave women central to the story. Three are
这些女性无法给予同意。对于奴隶主来说，这些女性在生产和再生产方面也具有价值。她们能在田里做多少工作。她们能生下多少被奴役的孩子，由于患有这些瘘管，她们无法继续生育，而且工作也会遇到困难。故事的核心有十名被奴役的女性。其中三名
named by Sims in his writing. These women were brought to him by their owners. The first woman was named Anarka. Anarka was a 17 year old enslaved woman who had just undergone a very traumatic delivery. Some sources say that she was in labor for three days. At first, he did not want to treat her. He was not interested in treating women, but then what he started to do from a period from 1845 to 1849, he did a series of experimental surgeries on these women. And he uses sutures to try to close up this opening. Now presumably this would have been painful. It was very painful and he talks about how
被西姆斯写进他的著作中并点名了。这些女性是被她们的主人带到他那里的。第一个女人名叫安娜卡（Anarka）。安娜卡是一名17岁的被奴役女子，刚刚经历了非常痛苦的分娩。有资料说她临产了三天。起初，他不想治疗她。他对治疗女性不感兴趣，但随后在1845年至1849年期间，他对这些女性进行了一系列实验性手术。他使用缝合线试图缝合这个开口。现在想来这一定很痛苦。这确实非常痛苦，他谈到
Lucy, one of the three women, almost felt as if she were going to die, that she cried out and pain so much because of these surgeries. But at the same time, he writes that the women wanted the surgery because they did not want to have the condition anymore. Were the surgeries that he was performing on them performed without anesthesia? They were performed without anesthesia. There was a belief at the time that black people did not feel pain in the same way. They were not vulnerable to pain, especially black women, so that they had suffered pain in other parts of their lives, and their pain was ignored. As Sims' reputation as a researcher grew, he began to invite other physicians to come
露西（Lucy）——三个女人中的一个——几乎觉得自己快要死了，由于这些手术，她痛得大声哭喊。但与此同时，他写道，这些女性想要做手术，因为她们不想再患有这种疾病了。他给她们做的手术是在没有麻醉的情况下进行的吗？这些手术都是在没有麻醉的情况下进行的。当时的观点认为，黑人并没有以同样的方式感受到疼痛。他们对疼痛不敏感，尤其是黑人女性，她们在生活的其他部分已经遭受过痛苦，因此她们的疼痛被忽视了。随着西姆斯作为研究人员的声誉日益提高，他开始邀请其他医生前来看
watch as he performed the surgeries. So this surgery was done where black women were naked. So when we think about it, I think we think about pain, we also need to think about how these women's dignity were also taken away from them. For a long time, the surgeries didn't work. Now, he's not successful at the beginning, and so that's why these surgeries went on from 1846 to 1849, and finally, after 30 surgeries on one woman, he was finally able to perfect his technique. That woman was Anatka. The two others who are named in Simpsons' papers are Betsy and Lucy. I asked Vanessa Gamble whether there was any way to know if these women actually wanted the surgeries.
他做手术。所以这个手术是在黑人女性赤身裸体的情况下进行的。因此当我们思考这件事时，我想我们除了考虑疼痛之外，还需要考虑这些女性的尊严是如何被剥夺的。在很长一段时间里，手术并没有成功。一开始他并不成功，所以这些手术从1846年一直持续到1849年，最后，在对一个女人做了30次手术之后，他终于完善了他的技术。那个女人就是安娜卡。西姆斯的论文中点名的另外两个人是贝茜（Betsy）和露西（Lucy）。我问瓦妮莎·甘布尔，有没有办法知道这些女性是否真的想要做手术。
We do not know that. The only thing we know is that Sim said that these women, one of the women, clamorously wanted to have the surgery. They wanted to be cured. One of the things in the story that's missing are the words and voices of the women themselves, not being translated by Sims. Sims, of course, has a self-interested reason to say that the women wanted what he was trying to do to them. Of course, he has an interest. And one of the interest is that it mutes the story of slavery slavery in his work, that it mutes the story that the foundations of modern gynecology are based on the body and the pain of enslaved black women.
我们并不知道。我们唯一知道的是，西姆斯说这些女性中有一个人强烈要求做手术。她们渴望被治愈。这个故事中缺失的一点是这些女性自己的话语和声音，而不是由西姆斯翻译出来的。当然，西姆斯有出于自身利益的理由去声称这些女性想要他对她们做的事情。他当然有利益诉求。其中一个利益诉求就是，这淡化了奴隶制以及他工作中奴隶制的故事，淡化了现代妇科学的基石建立在被奴役的黑人女性的身体和痛苦之上的这一事实。
The Statue in South Carolina that says that Sims treated Empress and slave women alike. Is that true? Was he treating white women the same way? He did treat white women, but he treated white women with anesthesia. Sims left in the 1850s. He left Alabama and moved to New York City for health reasons. And he started a woman's hospital in 1855 there. He gained a reputation as an excellent surgeon, and so that he did treat white women. But the technique
南卡罗来纳州的雕像上说西姆斯对待女皇和奴隶女性一视同仁。这是真的吗？他对待白人女性也是一样的吗？他确实治疗过白人女性，但他用麻醉剂治疗白人女性。西姆斯在1850年代离开了。出于健康原因，他离开阿拉巴马州搬到了纽约市。他在1855年那里创办了一家妇女医院。他获得了杰出外科医生的声誉，因此他确实治疗过白人女性。但这项技术
had been perfected on the bodies of black women. When you hear about a story that took place 150 years ago, there is a part of us that says that was pretty awful, but that was then, and this is now. But a lot of your work has actually tried to broaden that idea and said, yes, that was then, but some of what was then is also with us now. Right. I mean, one of the things that I teach a course on the history of race and racism in American
是在黑人女性的身上完善的。当你听到一个发生在150年前的故事时，我们内心的一部分会觉得这太糟糕了，但那是过去，现在是现在。但你的很多工作实际上试图拓宽这种观点，并指出，是的，那是过去，但过去的一些东西至今仍然伴随着我们。没错。我的意思是，我教授的一门课程是关于美国种族和种族主义的历史
medicine. And one of the things that I try to get across to my students is that racism is a very flexible, very adaptive concept. That, yes, black people are not thrown out of hospitals these days because they are black, or not excluded from hospitals because they are black. But our focus today is on what happens once one gets into the hospital. It's striking as you say this because I feel like I've read studies in the last few years looking at disparities in how people of color get treated for pain in the late
医学。我试图向我的学生传达的一点是，种族主义是一个非常灵活、适应性极强的概念。是的，黑人现在不会因为是黑人而被扔出医院，或者不会因为是黑人而被排斥在医院之外。但我们今天的重点是一旦进入医院会发生什么。当你这么说时，这让人震惊，因为我觉得我在过去几年里读过一些研究，探讨有色人种在晚期
20th century and the early 21st century. It feels like there is a thread between what happened 150 years ago and what's happening today. Right. I agree with you. I mean, because I think part of this story has to deal with how black bodies are conceptualized by the medical profession. There is a video that Johns Hopkins put out about people with sickle cell disease, and in this video, this woman says, when I go to the hospital, even though I'm in pain, I make
20世纪和21世纪初因疼痛而得到治疗的差异。感觉150年前发生的事情与今天发生的事情之间存在着某种联系。是的。我同意你的看法。因为我认为这个故事的一部分与医学界如何概念化黑人身体有关。约翰斯·霍普金斯大学发布过一段关于镰状细胞贫血症患者的视频，在这段视频中，这位女性说，当我去医院时，尽管我很痛，但我一定
sure I get dressed up. Because if I get dressed up, maybe I will be treated better and not be seen as somebody who is seeking drugs. So it still is there in terms of how the medical profession views black people and black bodies. It is true though that some of the things that Marion Sims discovered are still being used or in form medical practice today. He went on to become president of the American Medical Association. Exactly. He was a member of the New York Academy of Medicine. So this is a very conflicted
会精心打扮。因为如果我打扮得体，也许我会受到更好的对待，而不会被视为寻找毒品的人。因此，就医学界如何看待黑人及其身体而言，这种情况仍然存在。不过，马里恩·西姆斯发现的一些东西至今仍在使用或为今天的医疗实践提供借鉴，这也是事实。他后来成为了美国医学会的会长。没错。他是纽约医学会的成员。所以这是一个充满冲突的
legacy because presumably some of the things that he helps start or he helped invent are things that are of views to us today and we value and we benefit from that knowledge. And yet that knowledge was obtained at such great cost and I recently read a 2011 study that was done by physicians and they looked at medical textbooks to see how Sims was referred. He was referred as a father of modern modern gynecology, someone who perfected the surgical technique, but no discussion about his legacy in terms of conducting these experimental surgeries on enslaved women. So that's part of the problem. We can say that some of these surgeries that he did women today are benefiting from, especially in poor countries, but at the same time we can't forget how that came to be. I'm wondering as someone who is a physician herself, what do you think should be done with those statues? It's one of those things where I'm conflicted.
遗产，因为据推测，他帮助发起或帮助发明的某些东西对我们今天的日常生活很有用，我们珍视这些知识并从中受益。然而，这些知识是以巨大的代价获得的，我最近读了一位医生在2011年进行的一项研究，他们查阅了医学教科书，看看是如何提及西姆斯的。他被称为现代妇科学之父，一个完善了外科技术的人，但没有讨论他以对被奴役女性进行这些实验性手术为代价的遗产。所以这部分是问题所在。我们可以说，今天女性正在受益于他所做的一些手术，特别是在贫困国家，但与此同时，我们不能忘记这一切是如何实现的。作为一名医生，我想知道你认为应该如何处理这些雕像？这是我感到纠结的事情之一。
If you had asked me this question last spring, I would have given you a different answer. And I'll tell you why I'm conflicted. Last summer, I went to Liverpool. And Liverpool has a remarkable international museum of slavery. And one of the things that I did when I was in Liverpool, I took a slavery history tour because Liverpool was at the center of the transatlantic slave trade. And on an art deco building, there was an image of Neptune, since it's Liverpool and pool and water, and underneath Neptune there were two black children who were in chains. And the Torah guide who was an 80 plus year old black gentleman asked us, do you think this should be taken down?
如果你去年春天问我这个问题，我会给你一个不同的答案。我来告诉你我为什么纠结。去年夏天，我去了一趟利物浦。利物浦有一个非凡的国际奴隶制博物馆。我在利物浦时做的一件事是参加了一个奴隶制历史之旅，因为利物浦曾是大西洋奴隶贸易的中心。在一栋装饰艺术风格的建筑上，有一个海神的图像，因为这里是利物浦，有水，在海神下方有两个戴着铁链的黑人儿童。导游是一位80多岁高龄的黑人绅士，他问我们，你们认为这个应该被拆除吗？
And most people said yes. And he says, I think it should stay. And he said, I think it should stay, because I don't want people to forget it happened. And so, I think that we need to do something to commemorate the women. To add something to say, yes, Sims did this, but what about Anna? What about Lucy? What about Betsy?
大多数人回答说应该。而他说，我认为它应该保留。他说，我认为它应该保留，因为我不想让人们忘记它曾经发生过。因此，我认为我们需要做点什么来纪念这些女性。加上一些内容，说明：是的，西姆斯做了这些，但安娜卡呢？露西呢？贝茜呢？
I think if we don't do that, that people will forget what happened to those women. So as a historian and as a teacher, I think that it's important for people to know what happened to those women. And if we whisk away these images of Sims, people will forget. How do you hear what these women were going through? So if you could speak to Anarka and Lucy and Betsy, what do you think they will tell you? I think the story they would tell me would not start with Sims.
我想如果我们不这样做，人们就会忘记那些女性身上发生的事。因此，作为一名历史学家和老师，我认为让人们了解那些女性身上发生的事情是很重要的。如果我们把西姆斯的这些形象抹去，人们就会忘记。你如何看待这些女性所经历的一切？因此，如果你能与安娜卡、露西和贝茜对话，你认为她们会告诉你什么？我认为她们告诉我的故事不会从西姆斯开始。
I think the story they would tell me would be about their lives as enslaved women. It would begin there. It would begin how there were times where if that baby had survived, that the baby would have been taken away from them. They would talk to me about how as being black women, their bodies were used sexually, that they did not have consent, and that what happened to them with Sims was part and parcel of what their lives were at that particular time. But I think the other thing they would want us to know is that they were human beings and that they
我认为她们告诉我的故事将是关于她们作为被奴役女性的生活。故事会从那里开始。它将从以下方面开始：有时如果那个婴儿活下来了，婴儿就会被从她们身边夺走。她们会告诉我，作为黑人女性，她们的身体在性方面被利用，她们无法给予同意，以及她们在西姆斯那里遭遇的事情只是她们在那个特定时期生活的一部分。但我认为她们还希望我们知道的一点是，她们是人，她们
also deserve their story to be memorialized, that we have statues of Sims in Columbia, South Carolina, in New York City. There are portraits and medical schools of Sims. Where is their story? If you could build a memorial of Tu Anakabetsi and Lucy, or a memorial that stood alongside the memorials that we have erected to Marion Sims in South Carolina and New York City, what would the memorial say? The statue would not be of the experiments, because I think that it's important not just to think of them
同样值得将她们的故事载入纪念碑，我们在南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚市、在纽约市都有西姆斯的雕像。医学院里有西姆斯的肖像。她们的故事在哪里？如果你能为安娜卡、贝茜和露西建立一个纪念碑，或者建立一个与我们在南卡罗来纳州和纽约市为马里恩·西姆斯竖立的纪念碑并存的纪念碑，这个纪念碑会写些什么？雕像不会是关于那些实验的，因为我认为重要的是不要只把她们视为
as victims of these experiments. It might be with the three of them together, or it might be with their holding children, that they were mothers, that they were women. So that's what be part of it. So it would not be their prostrate on the altar of science. I think what the inscription would say is Betsy, Anarcha, and Lucy, the mothers of modern gynecology. In the woman, it is a checklist. Can you imagine anything worse than this?
这些实验的受害者。它可能是她们三个人的合影，或者可能是她们抱着孩子的形象，她们是母亲，她们是女性。所以这将是其中的一部分。因此，它不会是她们俯卧在科学祭坛上的样子。我认为碑文上会写着：贝茜、安娜卡和露西，现代妇科学之母。在女性中，这是一份检查清单。你能想象比这更糟糕的事吗？
If the answer is no, ask again. Bettina Judd is a professor of gender and women studies at the College of William & Mary. She's also a poet, and she recently wrote about a medical experience she had in a book called Patient, drawing not just on her personal history as a black woman, but the stories of Anika, Betsy, and Lucy. Produced a Maggie Penman spoke to Bettina Judd and asked her to read some of her poetry. In 2006, in her first year of graduate school, Bettina Judd had what she calls an ordeal with medicine.
如果答案是否定的，再问一次。贝蒂娜·贾德是威廉与玛丽学院性别与妇女研究系的教授。她也是一位诗人，最近她在一部名为《病人》（Patient）的书中写到了她的一次医疗经历，不仅借鉴了她作为黑人女性的个人历史，还借鉴了安妮卡（Anika）、贝茜和露西的故事。制作人玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）采访了贝蒂娜·贾德，并请她朗读了她的一些诗作。2006年，在读研究生第一年，贝蒂娜·贾德经历了一场她称之为与医学的艰难考验。
She was driving home from her part-time job and had to pull over because of a sharp pain in her abdomen. In 2006, I had an ordeal with medicine. I must have been found guilty of something. I don't feel innocent here lurking with ghosts. See, it happens like that. I started a thought that is quite benign and end up peckant to baste.
她当时正驾车从兼职工作的地方回家，由于腹部一阵剧痛，她不得不把车停在路边。2006年，我经历了一场与医学的艰难考验。我一定是被判定犯了什么罪。在这里与幽灵潜伏，我并不觉得自己无辜。看，事情就是这样发生的。我开始了一个相当良性的想法，却以被羞辱告终。
I had an ordeal with medicine and was found innocent or guilty. It feels the same because I live in a haunted house. A house can be a dynasty, a bloodline, a body. There was punishment, like the way the body is murdered by its own weight when lynched. Not that I was wrong, but that verdicts come in a bloodline. In 2006, I had an ordeal with medicine. To recover, I learned why ghosts come to me. The research question is, why am I patient?
我经历了一场与医学的艰难考验，被判无罪或有罪。感觉都一样，因为我住在一所鬼屋里。一个房子可以是一个王朝，一个血统，一个身体。曾有过惩罚，就像遭遇绞刑时身体被自身的重量毁灭那样。倒不是我错了，而是判决来自于血统。2006年，我经历了一场与医学的艰难考验。为了康复，我明白了幽灵为什么会来找我。研究的问题是，为什么我是个病人？
Bettina Judd had to be patient as a doctor told her she was having menstrual cramps and sent her home with painkillers A few days later she was told she had a bladder infection and given antibiotics She was repeatedly given pregnancy tests, though she had told doctors. She wasn't having sex with men She didn't know it at the time, but what she was suffering from was an ovarian torsion, a rotation of the ovary that makes it impossible for blood to flow to it. She was experiencing the death of one of her organs. There might be something called an impatient pregnancy test, Dr.'s whispers, my weak long funk sterile lubricant discarded speculums. Everywhere of morphine mimics a familiar morning, another dream of drowning in mucus, meeting a dead ovary.
贝蒂娜·贾德不得不表现得很有耐心，因为医生告诉她她只是在经期痉挛，并打发她带着止疼药回家。几天后，她被告知她患有膀胱感染，并得到了抗生素。她被反复进行妊娠测试，尽管她已经告诉过医生她没有跟男性发生过性行为。她当时并不知道，但她所遭受的病痛是卵巢扭转，即卵巢发生旋转导致血液无法流向卵巢。她正在经历她其中一个器官的死亡。可能会有什么叫做不耐烦的妊娠测试，医生们的耳语，我长达一周的怪病，无菌润滑剂，丢弃的窥阴器。到处都是吗啡，模仿着熟悉的早晨，另一个淹死在黏液中的梦，与一个死去的卵巢相遇。
She floats in yellow, spits ovum into the poison, wrinkles black and morning. Throughout this ordeal, Bettina kept thinking about an article she had read not long before she became ill, about J. Marion Sims, who operated on slave women in the 1840s. Ann Arca, Betsy, and Lucy began to haunt her morphine-fueled dreams. She tried to understand what was happening to her through their stories. Nurses ask me how much does it hurt on a scale from 1 to 10? Anarka Westcott, Betsy Harris and Lucy Zimmerman are taken into the care of reluctant country surgeon in Montgomery, Alabama.
她在黄色中漂浮，将卵子吐进毒药里，起皱变黑并迎来清晨。在整个苦难经历中，贝蒂娜一直想着她在生病前不久读过的一篇文章，关于J·马里恩·西姆斯，他在1940年代对奴隶女性进行了手术。安娜卡、贝茜和露西开始萦绕在她被吗啡刺激的梦境中。她试图通过她们的故事来理解自己身上发生了什么。护士问我，在1到10的范围内，有多痛？安娜卡·韦斯特科特（Anarka Westcott）、贝茜·哈里斯（Betsy Harris）和露西·齐默尔曼（Lucy Zimmerman）被带到阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利的一位不情愿的乡村外科医生那里照顾。
See blood on a white hospital sheet. Tell me I'm having menstrual cramps, Betsy's first birth. Send me home with oxycodone and ibupofen, Lucy months out of household duties. After five hours in triage, Annarka, his first Viseko vaginal fistula, and another prescription. In these three, Sims shapes his speculum, and vents his silver sutures, perfect protocol for proper handling of the female pelvis. We wake unannesticized or addicted to opium, children born, children disappeared, helpless,
看到白色医院床单上的血迹。告诉我我有经期痉挛，贝茜的第一胎。打发我带着羟考酮和布洛芬回家，露西离开家务几个月。在分诊台呆了五个小时后，安娜卡，他第一例膀胱阴道瘘患者，以及另一张处方。在这三个人身上，西姆斯塑造了他的窥阴器，发明了他的银缝合线，这是妥善处理女性骨盆的完美方案。我们在没有麻醉或对鸦片上瘾的情况下醒来，孩子出生了，孩子消失了，无助，
helpless. She kept being asked this question, what is your pain on a scale from 1 to 10? And she would ask herself, well, what is one? What is ten? If I say it's a ten, what will they think? They'll see me a young African-American woman alone. Will they think I'm looking for pain pills? I'll give it a seven.
无助。她一直被问这个问题，在1到10的范围内，你的疼痛程度是多少？她会问自己，好吧，1是什么？10是什么？如果我说这是10，他们会怎么想？他们会把我当成一个年轻的、孤身一人的非裔美国女性。他们会认为我在找止痛药吗？我给它打7分吧。
Betsy invents the speck of them. Fall 1845. Introducing the bent handle of the spoon I saw everything as no man had ever seen before from the story of my life by J. Marion Sins. I have bent in other ways to open the body, make space. More pliable than puter, my skin may be less giving. Great discoveries are made on cushion lessons and hard falls. Sins and vents the speckulum. I invent the wind sing. If you must of it, the looking away, the here or discovery. Finally, Bettina ended up in a third hospital,
贝茜发明了窥阴器。1845年秋。引入我锯过的勺子的弯曲手柄，我看到了前所未有的一切，摘自J·马里恩·西姆斯的《我的一生》。为了打开身体、腾出空间，我曾以其他方式弯曲。比锡更柔韧，我的皮肤可能没那么宽容。伟大的发现在软弱的教训和重重的跌倒中诞生。西姆斯发明了窥阴器。我发明了风歌。如果你必须这样做，移开视线，此地或发现。最后，贝蒂娜住进了第三家医院，
this time a teaching hospital in an African-American neighborhood in her hometown. One day after multiple pelvic exams, after questions about her sexual history, after her answer's not being believed, she had a moment of outburst. She sat aloud in a room full of doctors. Gynecology was built on the backs of black women anyway.
这一次是她家乡的一家非裔美国人社区的教学医院。在多次盆腔检查之后，在被问及她的性历史之后，在她给出的答案不被相信的一天之后，她情绪爆发了。她在满屋子医生的房间里大声说出来。妇科本来就是建立在黑人女性的脊背上的。
To the patient. Tears will only leave you wanting for water and more time. Which, as you know, will be spent waiting. It's been 10 years since Bettina Jad had her ordeal with medicine. Next week, she'll be in Columbia, South Carolina, and she's going to see the statue of Sins, which she says she hopes will stay up for now. Until we have a conversation about who Sims was, and who the women he operated on were. Until there's a statue of Ann Arca, Lucy, and Betsy, So we have a conversation about who Sims was and who the women he operated on were.
致患者。眼泪只会让你渴望水和更多的时间。正如你所知，这些时间都将耗费在等待中。距离贝蒂娜·贾德经历那场医学折磨已经过去十年了。下周，她将前往南卡罗来纳州哥伦比亚，她要去看看西姆斯的雕像，她说她希望这座雕像暂时保留下来。直到我们开始讨论西姆斯是谁，以及他手术过的女性是谁。直到有安娜卡、露西和贝茜的雕像，这样我们就能讨论西姆斯是谁以及他手术过的女性是谁。
Until there's a statue of Ann Arca, Lucy, and Betsy, the mothers of Gynecology, a statue she says that she hopes will be bigger than the statue of Sims. producer Maggie Penman and Bettina Jyne. Hidden Brain is produced by Karam Agar-Kallison, Maggie Penman and Max Nestrak. Find us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen to my NPR stories on your local public radio station. To subscribe to our newsletter, send an email to hiddenbrainatnpr.org with the word subscribe in the subject line. I'm Shankar Vedanthan and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
直到有安娜卡、露西和贝茜的雕像——妇科学之母，她说她希望这座雕像比西姆斯的雕像更大。制作人玛吉·彭曼和贝蒂娜·贾德。《隐藏的大脑》由卡拉姆·阿加尔-卡利森（Karam Agar-Kallison）、玛吉·彭曼和马克斯·内斯特拉克（Max Nestrak）制作。请在脸书、推特和Instagram上关注我们，并在您当地的公共广播电台收听我的NPR故事。要订阅我们的时事通讯，请发送电子邮件至 hiddenbrainatnpr.org，并在主题栏中输入单词“subscribe”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。该集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。